bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france emmanuel macron
qui avait salué la décision historique
d'anne alassane ouattara de ne pas se
représenter
mais le décès de son ex premier ministre
amadou gon coulibaly a changé la donne
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le président
français peut dire alassane ouattara que
ce troisième mandat c'est plutôt mitigé
justement c'est cette rencontre est une
rencontre aux idées à bâle embarrassante
nous avons tenté de faire des piloris au
niveau du bon journalisme au niveau du
service de presse de l'elysée pour
pouvoir prendre part ou du moins assisté
à cet événement depuis lors aucune
information au niveau de l'agenda de
l'elysée rien mais nous savons que c'est
une rencontre qui met certainement pas
lassant pour le président français
emmanuel macron et aussi pour le
président ivoirien alassane ouattara à
ce que l'on s'était satisfait c'était
tous les chefs de l'exécutif français
s'était satisfait du de la décision du
président ivoirien de ne pas se
présenter pour un troisième mandat lors
de lors de sa rencontre avec au congrès
en mars 2000 à mars dernier et après
cela vous même l'avait signifié après le
décès de son prêt ministre amadou gon
coulibaly
il est revenu sur sa décision le
président mâcon cela très très
embarrassé si c'est pas comment il va
lui dire le prennent à savoir aussi très
embarrassé face à ses étudiants il va
expliquer sa décision de revenir et
parle pas cela nous avons dû
d'opposition côte d'ivoire la position
de l'opposition qui demande à la france
malheureusement de 10 à savoir a dû
retirer sa candidature et ce qu'ils
étaient avant pour l'intervention de
l'extérieur de la communauté
internationale s'est tendu aujourd'hui
le cas ça va trinquer au pouvoir qui
sent envahie dit clairement que la
couette et puis soudain qu'inattendu
destruction de personnes là de jeudi
dernier vendeur
mardi deux nuls en deux teams et à côté
dans un restaurant dans une brasserie de
l'opéra bastille le directeur exécutif
de l ehtp le parti d'alassane ouattara
adama bictogo avait dit que la côte
d'ivoire est un pays souverain qui
n'attendait aucune instruction de la
france ni d'un quelconque président ou
de quelconques responsables de partis
politiques
c'est encore aujourd'hui en côte
d'ivoire nous pouvons dire souverainiste
et quand on est dans l'opposition on
demande un terrain souple la france
surtout que cette visite d'alassane
ouattara intervient quand même dans un
contexte assez compliqué en côte
d'ivoire il ya des tensions qui sont
suscitée par sa candidature est ce que
vous croyez réellement que la côte
d'ivoire est à l'aube d'une nouvelle
crise préélectorale voir post
électorales comme ça a été le cas en
2010 tous sens pour l'esa à s'écrire que
la situation est tendue à tous les
signes d'une des convulsions prochaine
l'opposition qui est vent debout le le
pouvoir qui est droit dans ses bottes et
l'opposition qui appelle au dialogue
avant d'aller à des élections apaisées
et le pouvoir qui demandent d'aller aux
élections
avant des discussions apaisées donc
voilà deux discours qui ne se rejoignent
pas quelque part qui se rencontrent
quelques problèmes je dirais qu'ils se
heurtent et quand on a vu tout récemment
après la mort du président ouattara de
se représenter à la magistrature suprême
dupuis lui si tout les événements qui on
parle d'une vingtaine de mots pour
l'instant et quand les partis politiques
annoncent qu'ils feront tout que cette
élection sur la papouasie côté mais qui
feront tout pour avoir des conditions
d'une élection très transparente
je pense clairement que beaucoup de les
conditions tous les voyants sont au
rouge ou indique que choriste peut-être
électorale à une crise post électorale
mais je parle avec beaucoup de prudence
en espérant que véritablement les
autorités politiques ivoiriennes que ce
soit du poids ou de l'opposition dont la
sagesse de son congrès de paris alors
c'est vrai vous l'avez vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il ya très peu de
d'informations sur ce tête à tête entre
alassane ouattara et emmanuel macron en
ce moment à l'elysée ça ça doit se
dérouler en ce moment puisque dans
l'entourage en tout cas du président
alassane ouattara on a annoncé sept
rencontres pour 13h si il n'y a pas de
position claire de la part de la france
quelles conséquences cela peut avoir
on sait que la france était quand même
un partenaire important pour la côte
d'ivoire notamment sur le plan
économique on se souvient également
qu'en 2010 la france elle est intervenue
lorsque la crise postélectorale a éclaté
en côte d'ivoire justement à toute la
france avaient été envoyés en côte
d'ivoire une raison principale que tout
le monde pour les observateurs de la vie
publique en côte d'ivoire connaissent
les relations particulières entre le
président d'alors de la france a dit
nicolas sarkozy et le couple a le couple
ohatra 7 à la santé
son épouse dominique ouattara c'est ce
qui a poussé nicolas sarkozy à engager
les forces françaises dans la crise
ivoirienne qui étaient aussi des
contentieux électoral mais vous faudra
aussi pu noter que ducasse est un moment
la france n'est plus le partenaire
publions exclusif économiquement de la
côte d'ivoire mr côte d'ivoire sgd une
position stratégique pour la france
quant aux 43e du mac continuent à
l'aéroport international de port brillet
il ya quelques idées les quelques
enjambées du port international
quand on sait que le 43e bima et la zone
de la zone stratégique lbo stratégique
du contrôle de l'opération barkan au
niveau du g5 tout ça il ya des
situations qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la
côte d'ivoire la france ne peut pas se
permettre que la côte d'ivoire est dans
une situation j'ai dit les deux des
stabilité
tu pouvais tulle et durable et ça je
pense que le président magniant ma peau
est conscient de ce live conscient de
positionnement de la côte d'ivoire on
sent que c'est la patinoire entre dans
une situation d'instabilité ça peut
avoir un effet j'ai dit les boules de
neige et c'est tellement contaminer les
autres pays qui font partie de 16
centièmes colonies et cela ne serait pas
intéressant comme en france elle même
temps le contrôle de cette partie de
l'afrique
je pense que pour ce que mader macumba
oil l'esprit véritablement ce sera le
métier la stabilité de le média de la
stabilité de la côte d'ivoire et au nom
de de cela je pense que tout cela que
les intérêts et colombie parce
qu'aujourd'hui en côte d'ivoire la
france n'est plus le partenaire
privilégié où est ce positif de la côte
d'ivoire pour milla était à 30-40 vous
évoquez barkan stabilité en côte
d'ivoire stabilité également au mali
c'est l'une des préoccupations du
président français il en sera sûrement
question lors de cette réunion à
l'elysée merci à vous jean paul rault
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
correspondant du quotidien ivoirien
l'intelligent d'abidjan et président de
l'union des journalistes ivoiriens de
france